if people believe or fans believe that
i'm gonna hire um
the messiah in here and it's gonna make
you know bring you to the promised land
in one year
i've got a few guys they should meet can
meet the tooth fairy they can meet santa
claus i got a bridge in brooklyn it's
not going to i hope it happens that way
i hope we can find that person and make
those changes in one year this is a
building process we are at the beginning
of a building process
[Music]
david tepper owner of the carolina
panthers and completely insensitive to
the fact that the month is december
there's a lot of kids out there waiting
for their annual visit from santa claus
i hope santa claus arrives again i've
tried to be a good boy all year a couple
other good boys joining us today peter
king chris sims it's pft live nbc sports
radio nbcs and hello to our friends in
the uk and ireland enjoying the program
on sky sports and i heard from some
folks yesterday who let me know chris
they did indeed stay up late to watch
the vikings and the seahawks play up
till 5 a.m local time watching that game
so we appreciate all you over there
guys look the news of the day ron rivera
out in carolina david tepper he's the
owner he can do whatever he wants and
you know peter king we talked about it
briefly in the little tv only stub at
the top of the program
it kind of felt like it was time for
david tepper to exercise control over
the team that's what he said and that's
what happens when you buy a team you
don't buy a team because you want to
employ the coach you buy a team because
you want to own the team and you're
eventually going to run the team the way
you see fit
and that's exactly what this is mike i
think
you know the the only thing i would say
uh about just in terms of longevity is
that
david tepper as well as other owners in
this league basically have a situation
where they feel like they want to get a
long-term guy
in there and you heard him talk about it
this is a building process
as long as he continues to have that
attitude i believe he's going to be
doing the right thing
but if he gets on this haslam train
where they're changing coaches all the
time they're changing general managers
all the time the process is going to
last a lot longer
yeah mike i mean the whole thing is uh
it's interesting
first off ron rivera had a great run i
do think it was time to move on i mean
it was nine years yes there was some
good a super bowl appearance but let's
remember out of those nine years there
was only three seasons of above 500
record okay so that's that's kind of
crazy when you like when you say that
out loud uh it's one of those things
that kind of shocked me when i saw it a
few weeks ago so uh you know from from
them moving on i'm not shocked and then
the other thing is of course they get
out in front of the coaching search and
not only within that you get out in
front of the coaching search and
start to talk to coaches that you might
be interested and get the cam newton
discussion going as well so to me
there's two things that really are
important to that organization right now
is what to do with cam newton is he the
future we're gonna move on and then of
course the biggest thing is you know
finding this head coach and does he want
cam newton as his quarterback as they
move forward
and i like the idea guys of implementing
the decision now once you know you're
gonna make it why begin the process of
identifying candidates behind the back
of your coach because chances are
somebody's going to say something to
someone it's going to get back to ron
rivera and then you're going to have
ugliness you're going to have a sense of
disrespect and what it also does it
gives ron rivera an opportunity to jump
into the pool of potential head coaching
candidates for other teams next year not
that it helped mike mccarthy in 2018 he
did not get even as much of a sniff from
any of the various vacancies that were
available adam gase is the one who
crash-landed on his feet and he was a
guy who was fired after the season ended
but now if you're out there and you're
thinking about potentially upgrading at
head coach ron rivera a two-time coach
of the year not once but twice
and 2015 and took the panthers to the
super bowl in 2015 and he's 2-0 lifetime
as a head coach against bill belichick
that's a nice little i would put that
line near the top of the resume peter
king as i dusted off for the looming
coaching carousel
yeah but i i i will
i'll just make this point remember last
year when mike mccarthy got whacked it
was right around this time mike first
week of december
and everybody said basically oh he'll
get a job
uh and not everybody but i thought the
prevailing feeling was that mike
mccarthy would get a job
and the prevailing feeling on monday was
oh he's gonna he'll he'll have his
picket jobs i'm not so sure about that
um and and i mean he might he there be
you know jerry jones might swoop him up
and
and he'll be the coach of the cowboys on
new year's day i don't know
but
don't take anything as a guarantee don't
take anything as a lock in a coaching
search
what happens if lincoln riley is out
there and everybody is looking at the
recent spate of brilliant offensive guys
who are hired they look at matt lafleur
they look at hey for even though they've
only got three wins cliff kingsbury
has really done a heck of a job in
arizona because everybody thought that
they were going to be absolutely awful
they're a competitive team for the most
part
but
i don't think it's a lock that ron
rivera gets a job i think it's likely
that he does
but there aren't gonna be very many
openings mike maybe only five
and when there's only five openings you
better have a guy who's gonna love you
does dave gettleman in new york
love ron rivera does he love him enough
to fire pat shurmur and hire ron rivera
i don't know we'll see
yeah well it's all i mean is dave
gettleman gonna be there that would be
my question off that i'm not so sure his
you know he's not on the hot seat
himself but you know i think that's
that's the real question and i do agree
with peter there i mean you know the the
common tread is offensive genius right
now develop a young quarterback we want
that type of guy so yeah ron rivera
doesn't fit that mold to me ron rivera
is going to have to fit in a place where
they feel like hey we're kind of ready
to win right now like this second you
know and if you just name the name the
the teams that we think possibly could
have coaching changes right mike i mean
it's the jaguars the browns the falcons
the redskins the giants the cowboys
right am i missing anybody else there
but i really think it's those six that
are kind of up in the air right now and
a few of those i think we know there's
definitely going to be a coaching change
the one that jumps out to me is the
browns now you know ron rivera is not an
offensive coordinator so they'd have to
sell something as far as the offensive
side of the ball but the browns are a
team that have a lot of pieces in place
right now to where i don't know if you
want that young upstart guy just trying
to figure out his way you know uh and
and become a first-time nfl head coach
with that type of team to me that's just
that's the big question there and kind
of the the interesting angle about all
of it
and i think he would fit with john
dorsey even though i don't think they've
worked together in the past ron rivera
doesn't strike me as the kind of guy
who's going to go in and try to take
over he has always colored within the
lines they had changes at gm he never
was there was never that sense he was
trying to make a power grab right he
just coaches the team right and i think
he would be an upgrade over freddie
kitchens because he's been there he's
done it he's taken a team to a super
bowl we've seen what he can do when he
has the pieces around him and as to the
giants hey ron rivera may be the guy who
saves dave gettleman if dave gettleman
senses some other coach is going to want
to run him off gettleman should be
banging on john mara's door today saying
how about hiring ron rivera because that
does save
dave gettleman if rivera ends up being
the head coach potentially and speaking
of gm we've got to move on to that side
of the equation we don't know what's
going to happen with marty harney david
tepper gave us some clues some obscure
vague clues about the future of marty
herney he had a press conference
yesterday here he is when asked
specifically what happens with your
general manager
marty herney is one of the it's an
incredible um well well not given that
kind of compliment he's i think he's a
very good um
um
evaluator of college talent
he is
you know put in that position he is very
successful you can look at the track
record it's pretty successful track
record
um
you know in a modern organization i
think you need somebody else in that
organization to complement that
okay
we don't want to give them too good of a
compliment because we want to reserve
the right to follow we already did
it's already out you can't here's the
thing david tepper look you've you've
made billions and you've been a highly
successful business person once the
word's out of your mouth it can't come
back it's gone let it go and just keep
moving but if you know what i take from
this peter
he's reserving the right to make changes
the kind of changes that may undermine
marty herney they may relegate him to
essentially glorified director of
college scouting and have someone else
to handle pro-personnel
the overall operation of the football
side of the business with hernia having
a very narrow focus that he is
incredible oh wait i mean very good at
doing
yeah you know that's one of the ones i'm
sure that when david temper watches the
tape as all coaches do that's one of the
ones he'd like to have back
um as you say mike he might be great at
business but
he uh he might need a
a press conference lesson or two
um you know two points i guess i would
make first of all marty herney is the
guy not dave gettleman who drafted you
know the two bedrock players that led
this team to the super bowl that's right
you know cam newton and uh and luke lee
so that has to be
you've got to remember that and i think
secondly
you know david tepper right now i
believe doesn't know what he wants
you know he doesn't he's he's too early
in this process
i mean look far be it for me you know to
suggest how a guy should handle
something like this
but
the easiest thing to do at a time like
this is to say i don't know
i don't know what we're going to do
everything is on the table i'm not sure
i really like marty hernias great
but i'm not sure what we're going to do
you need to give us time to figure that
out yeah i think that's the big thing
you got to figure out who you want as a
head coach right and the relationships
maybe they have or the vision they have
of a team to where you know you want to
course have a cohesive relationship
between a gm and a head coach and that's
going to be important as far as you know
hiring a head coach and oh does he like
marty herney or is marty herney build a
team the way you know he envisions the
team playing around his scheme and
everything like that those are the big
questions david tepper is going to have
to figure out here marty herney i do i'm
like i'm with peter there he's a very
valuable asset he understands how to
build a football team i'm a fan of his i
always have been i mean he he collects
big people
as far as you know offense and defensive
lineman carolina's one of those teams
over the last 10 years they don't go
into games and you ever go oh they're
gonna get overpowered up front so to me
he always starts there and he does have
a good eye for talent so i don't know
where it goes from there but i do think
like to what peter said the big question
is he's got to figure out what he's
thinking as far as head coach and then
when you go to head coach you start to
figure out okay does marty herni make
sense with this guy as we go forward or
do i need to just scrap the whole front
office department and get a new gm and
everything with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports